intensely blue the waters around Bermuda
are warmed by the Gulf Stream one of the
world's largest and swiftest ocean
currents up back whales pass through
these waters each year migrating from
polar feeding grounds
these waters are also known to legions
of luminous deep-sea creatures and
intrepid undersea explorers in the 1930s
zoologist William Beebe and engineer
Otis Barton descended a thousand metres
into the depths around Bermuda for a
first view of life in a place sunlight
never reaches
maybe compared what he saw to naked
space itself now far beyond that is in
between the stars with a blackness of
space
the shiny planets comets suns and stars
it was really closely akin to the it
appears to the umpires appalled human
being
the open ocean 1/2 mile down
for baby and Barton the Comets suns and
stars were living creatures reflecting
rainbows of iridescent flashing sparkly
white
fireflies glow worms are famous light
makers of the land but in the deep sea
90% of the creatures jellyfish interior
trim and squids and many others have
some form of bioluminescence to signal
one another scientists say these bursts
starry light may be the most common form
of communication on the planet in the
open sea jellies are also among the most
abundant forms of life the Gulf Stream
current can carry these oddly beautiful
drifters along at about 160 kilometres a
day
buffered by the Gulf Stream is a
magically quiet gently rotating mass of
Sargasso weed that expands over more
than five million square kilometers of
open quarters
isolated my walls and fast-moving
currents between Bermuda and Puerto Rico
the Sargasso Sea holds the good young
creatures which have evolved over the
ages to exist in floating forests
golden-brown Sargassum within its leafy
Sun that masses are camouflaged such
creatures as loggerhead turtles filefish
sea hares and the speckled brown sword
gasps Oh crab
four scientists is a living laboratory
strategically located in the open sea
creatures that live in the undersea
caves on the reefs and in the great
depths of low is simply home